a number of Democratic senators are
demanding an explanation from the EPA
today about why it put a leading
children's health expert on paid leave
without warning that expert dr. Ruth
Etzel spoke only to CBS this morning
earlier this week at least eight US
senators were watching and sent letters
criticizing the EPA's move they say it
raises serious concerns about the
agency's commitment to children's health
and a Warner has been following this
story anyhoo got a lot of people talking
and being attention good morning good
morning there's a lot of reaction to
this story since our interview with dr.
Ruth Etzel aired on Monday
many people have spoken out to support
her some calling her a hero for going
public with her concerns about what's
happening at the office of Children's
Health Protection and some members of
Congress are speaking up too it's
absolutely outrageous saw what's
happening a doctor at Sola
that's the reaction of Democratic
Senator Chris Van Hollen of Maryland to
the sidelining of dr. Ruth Etzel the
director of the EPA's office of
Children's Health Protection here's
somebody who's been the champion for
children at the EPA who all of a sudden
without any notice is put on
administrative leave
dr. Etzel is the top expert whose job is
to advise the EPA on how its regulations
might affect children but she says in
the current administration our message
is no longer welcome over three weeks
ago
EPA officials put her on paid leave she
says without explanation it's about
silencing me because I know how to
protect children and I've got a track
record I'm doing it for 35 years EPA
later said in a statement that there
were serious reports made against her by
staff regarding her ability to
effectively lead but this former EPA
Regional Administrator doesn't buy it
she was widely respected as a competent
leader within the Environmental
Protection Agency Judith ank says she
worked closely with dr. Etzel during the
Obama administration dr. Ruth Etzel is
just a tremendous expert an advocate for
children everyone who has a child or a
grandchild in the United States should
be concerned about this move
in a response to senators the EPA did
not give further explanation for its
actions regarding dr. Etzel but senator
Van Hollen says well what's happened to
dr. Etzel is unfortunately a part of a
much larger story of what's happening to
EPA which is an attack on scientists and
an attack on science EPA also told the
Senators there are no plans to cut
funding or resources from the children's
health office
but these Democratic senators tell us
they're not comfortable with what they
see happening at the EPA and when it
comes to experts like dr. Etzel yeah we
think a lot of people now we're gonna
start paying more attention and will
want to talk to her John you made the
really good point about people like dr.
Etzel
what Michael Lewis was talking about in
his book well they're throughout a
government yeah who spend their lives
dedicated no you know honor or glory
they just do their job and protect
people and there are lots of them in the
government that people don't know about
so it's this great specific story but a
great light on a lot of work we'll
continue to follow her yeah thank you